in the last few moments the senior
conservative mp william rag has accused
conservative party whips and number 10
staff of blackmail of mps who want a
vote of confidence in the prime minister
he says his colleagues have been
threatened with withdrawal of funding
from constituencies and he's encouraged
them to contact the police we can hear
what he's got to say now
in recent days a number of members of
parliament have faced pressures and
intimidation from members of the
government because of their declared or
assumed desire for a vote of confidence
in the party leadership of the prime
minister
it is of course the duty of the
government whips office to secure the
government's business in the house of
commons
however it is not their function to
breach the ministerial code in
threatening to withdraw investments for
members of parliament's constituencies
which are funded from the public purse
additionally
reports to me and others of members of
staff at number 10 downing street
special advisers government ministers
and others
encouraging the publication of stories
in the press
seeking to embarrass those who they
suspect of lacking confidence in the
prime minister
is similarly unacceptable
the intimidation of a member of
parliament is a serious matter
moreover
the reports of which i'm aware would
seem to constitute blackmail
as such it would be my general advice to
colleagues to report these matters to
the speaker of the house of commons and
the commissioner of the metropolitan
police and they're also welcome to
contact me at any time
before we begin our questions could i
ask mr barkley
to confirm that he will convey the
spirit of this statement to the
government i will
and could i ask mr chisholm uh if he
would ensure that civil service will
respond as necessary yes thank you both
political correspondent tamara cohen is
in western sir tomorrow i mean it's just
going to carry weight i mean the whips
are always pretty heavy-handed with mps
aren't they
they are and i think this uh senior mp
who has already said that he wants boris
johnson to resign he said that a few
days ago he was one of the early ones
calling for it is now trying to say to
the whips look call off the dog stop
going he says too far with some of these
conservative mps i think there is
concern in the party that the names have
been leaked of those who are said to be
the ring leaders of these plots against
the prime minister have been leaked to
the media and now he's saying that the
whips are going so far that they are
what they're doing would uh constitute a
matter for the police so some pretty
strong accusations uh which are intended
to try and calm down what uh he sees as
a heavy-handed whipping operation i
would say that just before christian
wakeford the mp who was a conservative
yesterday morning and had become a
labour mp by lunchtime just before he
defected we had been told by a colleague
of his that he had been threatened by
party whips with his seat being
abolished in boundary changes in order
to try and keep him in the party um so
if there are any accusations made
publicly that would breach the
ministerial code that would be very
damaging but at the moment he is just
trying to send a message we'll see how
effective it is